all right sandra back now to our top
story in the growing calls for
transparency in the investigation into
the origins of the covid19 pandemic
senior fellow at the hudson institute
david asher joins us now
he is a former state department official
who led a probe into the pandemic under
former secretary of state
mike pompeo david good to see you just
to set this up for the folks at home
this is the investigation that we were
reporting on yesterday that was shut
down in the spring
by the biden administration you left
that investigation about the end of
january or so
what was that investigation finding
well we were finding that uh despite the
claims of our scientific community uh
including the national institutes of
health and dr fauci's
ny aid organization that there was
almost no
evidence that supported the natural
zoonotic
uh uh you know evolution
or uh source of cobit 19. i
i i came into an investigation uh doing
a compliance report related to the bio
weapons treaty
and we said you know okay let's look at
the both both
both both sources of evidence natural
zoonosis as they call it
you know they came out of nature or did
it come out of a lab
and the data disproportionately stacked
up
as we investigated that it was coming
out of a lab or some
supernatural source but but at that
point in time the person who was
overseeing this the under secretary for
nonproliferation
chris ford you say didn't really want to
entertain this idea
no no he he seemed disinterested
he said even if we came to it how do we
know where it came out of what lab
i i very rarely in my in my life in
government i've ever encountered someone
who's more of a megacrat
less a bureaucrat than that individual
uh uh is i i i
rarely say that i encountered
disgraceful
behavior in government but uh i did
actually on this occasion
that you say they're very bizarre you
you say that you were
looking into compliance in terms of uh
weapons of mass destruction arms control
was there a military component to this
of course i mean we were trying to
assess the entire
biological weapons program of china and
i have a background in biotech investing
and that's why i came back as a
contractor because they couldn't afford
to uh
come back into government as a regular
official uh this last time uh but i
still had an official capacity more or
less
and i i know i knew a lot about
synthetic biology and i
i i i i rapidly zeroed in on the wilhelm
institute of virology not just because
of the secretary of state's previous
uh statements about it but because that
was the center or the epicenter of
synthetic biology
in the people's public china and they
were up to some very hairy stuff
with synthetic biology and so-called
gain of function
techniques so what do you believe
through the intelligence that you
gathered your task force gathered
that the chinese were doing at that
institute when it comes to coronavirus
well they were doing a wide variety of
things
it's interesting until 2015 the chinese
as
members of the biological weapons
convention declared
that they were engaged in coronavirus
related research
and then in 2016 they stopped declaring
that
for and this was for biodefense purposes
ostensibly
so why did they stop declaring it well
as we
uh unveiled in our uh declassified
statement from the secretary of state
and dni on january 15th
they had kicked off in 2016 at the exact
same time a classified program involving
the people's liberation army
into coronaviruses with a biological
weapons element obviously present
now dr fauci has maintained from the nih
that american money was not used to fund
gain of function research
at wuhan uh you suggested that they were
involved in gain of function research
there at that laboratory
did you find anything to connect the
dots between
nih funding and what was going on at the
lab
yeah you know i mean i wasn't involved
in in uh researching the chinese the uh
the the uh the the us government's uh
involvement in gain of function research
i was thinking the chinese governments
but via looking at the chinese side of
this
but the chinese most certainly felt that
nih was supporting their gain of
function research
and to enhance enhancing the
pathogenicity or
the the the virulence of uh coronavirus
uh
vectors that were radically unnatural
they were not
similar to anything that resembled what
could occur in natural evolution
in fact i had biostatisticians at one of
our national labs
calculate the odds of this evolving in
nature and it was like 1 in 13 million
and then
later revised it to about 1 in 13
billion
so you know to say this came out of a
zoonotic uh
situation is sort of ridiculous so just
very quickly because
i've only got a few seconds left here
david uh when all is said and done with
this 90-day review by the intelligence
committee
community what do you believe they'll
find what do you think they'll conclude
i have a lot of confidence the
intelligence community at this stage i
think they finally got their heads
around
this situation i think they'll find a
lot whether they'll
say much is a different matter we made a
big effort under secretary pompeo's
leadership to declassify critical
information
i certainly hope and i know that
congress endorses this
uh bipartisanly that this administration
will do the same
we need to find out truth for the sake
of our future
and humanity we'll see where this goes
and we'll keep watching it david ashley
good to see you again it's been a while
thanks so much for joining us really
appreciate it